- As always, lets finish
up with a little good news
trending on social,
this is What I'm Liking.
(upbeat music)
(audience cheering)
For decades, Sister Libby
worked with the Sacramento
non-profit supporting the
unhoused in her community.
Then, five years ago, she
had an even bigger idea.
Instead of helping from a building,
why not go to the people
directly on the streets.
Since then, she's built
up an army of volunteers
and they're easy to spot on any given day,
because they show up on bicycles.
They call it, "Mercy Peddling."
To tell us more about it, let's say hello
to Sister Libby, everybody.
Hello!
- Hello, Kelly.
- Hello, that is a really cool bike.
I'm gonna lead with that, first of all.
But, tell us more about how you help.
- Well, first of all,
I'm a Sister of Mercy
for over 32 years, and I was inspired
by the sisters actually
doing the works of mercy,
going out in the streets
and doing Matthew 25.
Especially, "When I was
homeless, you gave me shelter."
- Yeah.
- So, we Mercy Peddlers use these trikes
and we go out in different neighborhoods
connecting with those
who are on the streets,
and we bring water, and nutritional bars,
hygiene items, soap,
shampoo, and a lot of love.
- Aw, I love that.
So, you offer more than
just food and supplies
though, right?
- Oh, absolutely.
Our ministry is really based
on a sense of presence,
dignity and respect.
So, over time we grow
in a mutual relationship
of trust and care, so then we
can ask the deeper questions.
"How can I receive shelter today?"
"Do you need housing?"
"Do you have any recovery programs?"
"What about mental health services?"
So, we get to those deeper questions
and then we connect with
other community organizations
to help them make that major, major step
off of the streets.
- Absolutely, which is the whole point.
Thank you so much, Sister Libby.
You've got such a great heart.
I'm liking your post right now, alright?
And, that's not all.
That's not all, ma'am.
Our season long partner, Pilot Pen,
makers of G2, the go to pen
of the Kelly Clarkson Show,
want to celebrate people like you,
making a big impact in their community.
So, they are giving Mercy
Peddlers a thousand dollars,
how's that sound?
(audience cheering)
- That is so great.
Your care is gonna really touch those
who are on the streets.
God bless you.
- [Kelly] Aw, God bless you, too.
Thank you so much, and thank
you to all of our guests
this hour, Meghan Trainor,
Dara Selvara, Tom Colfree,
Jeremy Ford and Lawrence
Erin, y'all have a great day,
and if it's not, try and change it.